all right Vinnie Mack yes Vinnie Mack
yes where'd you grow up where are you
from originally amen they called me
Vinnie Mack the five star general I'm
Long Beach finest man out of Long Beach
California man tell me about how you
grew up I grew up as a nickel and dime
Hustler when I was a young kid I saw
weed when I was young uh then we we you
know of course Long Beach is is a [ __ ]
City so I was one of the founders of the
Crips back in the days I did my hustling
in the streets Dan and then uh I ended
up learning about the game as usual the
two books Iceberg Slim and Donald goines
I didn't like Iceberg Slims but because
he was trying to you know he's really
mean to women and stuff like that I'm
not into that you know my name is Vinnie
Matt I'm a Mac I'm not you know if I got
to put my hands on you I don't need you
I don't believe in all that type of uh
Mac is more like a gentleman pimp yes
sir I I could really consider myself as
a perceptional gentleman at leisure you
know what I mean
and she got introduced to the game early
yes now I'm gonna kick back and I'm
gonna take you in the ride you get in
the back seat let me tell you this story
Mark I cut my teeth right here across
the street back about 20 years ago this
was a major hole stroll right here with
your Studios at right here Mark I used
to park my car right across the street
so my girl she used to work right here
to make my ends meet I would work three
or four whole strolls a day to make
everything come together so I when I
when I cut my teeth in Hollywood in 1978
I had a a giant a legend was Hollywood
snake and we was part of the old
Hollywood division and when I got with
him we toured the country together Snape
was a pimp who had on the girl had snake
tattooed on their face ah I heard that
yeah that's it that's Hollywood snake
and on the ankle so I I came up under
him you know I I I came up in Long Beach
of course I got my Stacy Adams on
because in Long Beach you know that's
from the gangsterism versus Stacy Adams
all the real gangster with slack Stacy
Adams abused real sophisticated we kind
of modeled ourselves after Al Capone but
the stations on the slacks I didn't have
to think armbands on here had the Hat
linked to side at the time you know this
wasn't this is all while I was in high
school I was always a really nice
dresser you understand what I'm saying
so what happened was
when I cut my teeth in Long Beach and
snakes even though he's Hollywood snake
he was actually from Long Beach and so
when he cut into me I I was I was had a
couple of girls at the time and uh this
is what happened mark it was a guy that
came to town his name was Billy Joe he
came from Alaska he was 10 Deep they had
two sets of twins I admired the man so
much but you know what happened marked
when you admire man so much and you talk
about a man so much in the household he
knocked me from one of my girls and you
talking about a bad feeling ask Andy
pimp when you get knocked for one of
your brawls it's getting worse than
punched in the stomach in the jaw at the
same time and shot in the foot you dig
what I'm saying man so if any people
tell you they don't really talk about it
on there but what when they knock your
boy it's a cold feeling but anyway you
know I I overcame that nap with my first
knocking I got with snake and then we
end up going on the road we worked
Hollywood for a while we didn't go on
the road I was like five deep and snake
stayed between 9 and 13 deep so we we
left from down here we went up to
Bakerfield on Union and handled 13 women
at the same time well I only had six
it sounds chaotic well and let me tell
you something about that it's a good
thing that you said that Mark do you got
to put this in perspective I'm six deep
right but I must have went through 50
women to get six girls to jail together
you see what I'm saying because you
don't just get six deep in everybody's
State you got all these different and
personalities some of them like each
other some of them don't so you know
when somebody say they're six deep they
don't get behind the story how you got
the six deep you go you know because
you're dealing with all kind of mental
issues that sometimes you got all these
different challenges with different
women and they have to gel together and
fit together or not you take all them
girls together and you don't really know
them guess what's gonna happen you're
gonna get knocked again you know say
what I'm saying and so by that happening
not trying to tighten up my game but
snake was a real master at the game to
be 9 to 13 deep consistently on a
consistent basis man-to-man was game was
so heavy you know it seemed like the
ground would shake when he'd walk you
know I'm saying I got the pleasure of
meeting uh when we was in Hollywood I
met Bishop Don Juan I met a Detroit slim
yes they want to send something you know
of course you uh uh it was Joe cater was
back in the day he had to he's about and
Joe kale by the way is like 30 deep you
talking about deep he was like 30 deep
with two Rolls Royce a real master the
Minx and all that you know what I'm
saying I'm saying and if you went into
Cato country nine times out of ten you
was gonna get knocked so anyway so we
back to the story we we we start
mounting up and we started he took me he
took me he showed me how to go
International so we went to Bakersfield
it was on Union at the time it was about
80 90 girls working but snake told me
Vinnie all we do is mess with major
tracks so we want our name to go out
there we got Long Beach on our backs we
from the Hollywood division yesterday
I'm saying we're going to take this on
the road and at the time man we was
dressing since we was from the West
Coast we had Cowboys had linked to the
side we had the long perm with the
shingle coats on with the dripping when
we wore cowboy boots and stuff like that
so we had our own flavor for the west
coast and so we went from Bakersfield we
worked down through there then we went
to Fresno on Blackstone the parkway then
we ended up going up to it was a little
city called Salinas
Salinas was is it Northern California
right out of Oceanside Salinas was a
little British place in the host Road
Mark was only three blocks long but
guess what mark it was 90 girls in them
three blocks and when we got there man
it was like a lot of international pimps
I got to say and I want to say this here
this is where I met Kenny red at I don't
say rest in peace his funeral is coming
up you do know that he passed away I've
had Kitty red I met gangster Brown I met
Pippin Pierre Mario all of these were
the Bay Area fellas so we was kind of we
came together right there and I met a
couple International Players sleepy out
of New York uh uh Lucky out of Detroit a
lot of international players but when
you're on the track it was it was more
of a camaraderie than you know it was
uplifting it wasn't it wasn't like the
game is today so we went on to stomp
down around there then we went into the
Oakland the Bay Area you know I worked
up there for years I had some family
that stayed up there for about uh 30
years I was back and forth there then we
worked in the tenderloin you know then
we went up to Portland you know
Washington Seattle at these times all
these hotels 30 40 50 100 girls on all
these tracks I never went to little
small places you know what I'm saying
I'm a major pimp and I still I would
stick out like a sore thumb you know I
got my Cadillac I got tipping eight easy
on the back I got some ladies on the
back I got all these white girls in the
car so we tried to stay International on
big tracks
and you've
you've stayed out of prison during your
career no no no no no I I was on
vacation with a stipulation yes I was I
I did my time I did the crime and I did
my time and I'm back Jack you did yeah
so and so yeah I I went through that I
went through that you know you're going
to go through that in the game you know
but I was under demand act by the way
that should say enough and you know I
went on to that's when I I certain my
book American Fence Divinity Mac story
that's why I wrote the book at in prison
so that's that's where I got the
inspiration at well I took a dark turn
in there when my mother passed away when
I was I was I was incarcerated and so I
ended up being in a federal hole for
about nine months and I started writing
my book then so the guard would come by
and say hey what are you doing I said
man he said I see you writing every day
you're getting ready for your case I
said no I'm actually writing the book
and I told him about mother died he said
um I ain't supposed to do this but I'm
going to take you in a law library and
let you start the typing it Mark and
that's how the book came about I want to
get too far off the track but since you
asked me about the jail situation I
thought I would explain it a little bit
more so you know that's that's where I
pinned the book like I said and drugs
are part of your life no no I don't I
don't I don't I don't really care for
drugs but I'm telling you something
right now Mark anybody said
oh no my girls never use drugs it's more
than likely lying because see The Dark
Secret in the game is you really didn't
talk about what your family did because
if you talked about what your family did
they gave the other people advantage of
being in the inside of your home of
course everybody at one time that had a
drug addict or two and I'm not going to
even lie and say I ain't never had one
you did what I'm saying it happens but
you know either either but the situation
is you want them to try to come up out
of the game you know you want to try to
uplift them off a dope and then nine
dimes out of ten if I couldn't get get
them off with dope more than likely they
would run off because that's what they
really wanted to do and sometimes they
were hard to manage you know what I mean
but you know everybody goes through that
though so like I said once again they
said they never had no girl on some dope
they probably lying and Vinnie Mack said
that so you know I know you did that
past interview and they kind of chopped
the white boy real bad but you can check
my record yes I'm saying that's why I'm
putting it down in the ground so I'm an
international player for real you dig
what I'm saying man what was your
childhood like huh what was your
childhood like you had oh man my
childhood was magnificent my mom worked
at uh a uh Douglas aircraft and my dad
my stepfather worked at Douglas aircraft
they bought a new car she made the
newspaper and all that my childhood was
perfectly fine I had a wonderful job and
I was pretty smart kid and by the way
what's your parents attitude about the
direction in your life took
well
my mother was like this because my
stepfather died when I was young
and uh you know she she didn't really
really really really care for it but
then you know she supported me in
whatever I did but you know what I'm
saying but she didn't really care for
the lifestyle that I led you know what
I'm saying and you know I felt like kind
of like the black sheep of the family so
to speak you know what I'm saying and uh
you know that was that was her take on
it so I I actually took a little break I
had I had had some uh two two of my kids
was by one of my girls and when she left
I ended up having getting full custody
of my kids so I took a break from the
game to start taking them to school
I started going to college because I
want to be a you know a good father and
you know if I'm telling you go to school
if I'm not going to so that's what took
me back to to college and where I took
up radio and television and I was in
marketing themselves like I said I took
32 courses learned all aspects of that
game you know what I'm saying but during
that time I had had a heart attack and
then I find myself I'm not going to
college I'm not getting my grandmother
now here I'm a father right and I got
these kids I need to raise and then I
got back into the game back to my
mother's Point she said you took your
ass to college you got all that [ __ ]
education and then you got your ass back
in this [ __ ] that was where I had to do
more
God Rest our soul
what's more important to You Love or
Money
you know what uh love is more important
to me than money you can always make
money you can't make love you have to
fall in love or be in love you make all
the money in the world but you can't
make love you've been in love before you
know what Mark I'm telling you something
right now I've had a whole bunch of
women
and I'm gonna tell you something right
now anyone's with me I loved all my
women because if a woman goes out on the
track
takes a risk to risking their life
giving you all our money and you don't
love that woman you got a hole in your
soul man
and you're doing what's for the girl
when she's bringing you all the money
well you know what Mark you know
I did a lot of things Mark you got to
realize in this game it ain't it ain't
no 401K in the game right so I would
give my girls a daily allowances that
they got a chance to put away
all their father refers and it in my
program Mark every 30 days I would buy
my woman some type of jury you
understand what I'm saying for 500 start
off you know it may it's the longer with
three thousands of dollars now they got
to keep all of that their allowance all
the Furs the cars and the money so when
they did when they got out of the game
at least they would have something to
fall back on if they started to retire I
didn't have none of them go get with
another pip and gave them all the assets
that they had built up in that line
nothing like that a lot of people don't
know Mark in this game today the life
expectancy of a girl in the game is only
about five years if you keep a girl past
five years you're really doing something
because they grow tired of the game you
know in and out of running around and
doing all these different aspects of the
game and then it's dangerous and I'm
gonna tell you something else Mark that
a lot of people don't know when me
personally every time before my girls
went to work I would hold hands and be
in the prayer circle because I was
actually raised in church you understand
what I'm saying so I pray for my girls
and I'm gonna tell you something else
Mark that a lot of people don't know
since the game is so dangerous my main
girls I send them the self-defense
classes
yes I was saying so if they got in any
type of situation they'll be able to
handle themselves they figure they just
some hookers but boy they'll they'll
whoop the dog [ __ ] at you because you
get to messing around whatever you jack
you got another Fame coming messing with
Vinnie Mac's team you dig what I'm
saying man
yeah so your style is different than the
the the
stereotypical pimp oh yeah oh yeah quite
different quite different you know you
know in this situation it's all about a
lot of times it's not all pimps and I
don't want nobody trying to do no
rebuttal on Vinnie Mac to pimp you dig
what I'm saying all pimps ain't the same
Mark you got the characteristic of pimps
you got to remember a pimps is a hose
manager right but you got to realize
Pippin is one thing Pippin is a job but
they're men before The Pimps right and
it depends on the attitude of the man
when he gets in the game where people
selfish if he was brutal if he was mean
and he got in the game those are same
characteristic he brought into the game
you know this is a gentleman's game man
you know this this is a hands-off sports
man you know I'm not going to go through
all that all that how would you feel I
know how I know what I know one thing if
I was with somebody and they beat me
before they went to sleep they more than
likely they not gonna wake up yeah and
so I felt the same way you know what I
mean because you know in the game you
know you can find a lot of cases where
where hookers had actually killed her
cases here in California one of the
girls was getting out finally from from
that and they have several other cases
of that so you you know you kind of
underestimate your girls and and if you
like I said depends on the man itself
Pippin is one thing but we all men first
Mark you see what I'm saying so it
depends on how you were you know what I
mean how is it how has the game changed
in all the years you've been doing it oh
Mark let me tell you something man I'm
gonna give you the game has changed
let me give you a couple examples the
the time has changed for one thing and
I'll tell you something let me put this
out here mark
all the hookers
choose their pimps or what they
so-called films right so what happens
was when when they end up choosing a
gang banger a drug dealer or something
like that and then they have a bad
mishaps in the game they say they hate
pimps but they never had a pimp in the
first place they took somebody else and
tried to make them appealth but there
wasn't pimps in the first place so the
game has changed because those type of
people got in the game they didn't learn
the game see I learned from Hollywood
snake a true veteran I learned watching
gangster Brown feel more slim a bishop I
watched them come up you know I came up
right but the days guys they don't want
to have ah he's OG ah he didn't want to
hear nothing you got to say you
understand what I'm saying so what
they're doing is they're making up their
own style of the game Mark and what they
didn't infiltrated all this gangsterism
and and this drug dealing all this
deception and being brutal means so they
just stepped up the game Real High you
know a regular whole case a pimp case
you get from about 16 months
six years now the feds have stepped in
you'd like to get 10 20 30 40 life
triple life depending on your record you
see what I'm saying so the by the MP
those people are getting in the game not
really know what they're doing and be
getting pimp cases but that don't mean
they're pimps they just have got it and
let me say every month every guy that
receives money from a hoe ain't no vent
Mark you understand what I'm saying it's
a different that's how that's what then
then got in the game I'm gonna give you
a perfect example mark
I was out on Figueroa about five months
ago right
I was out there with I got some some
banners that I put on my car I bought my
book America pip the Mini Max story
right I pulled into the gas station bar
guess what that marked
free gunman ran up on my car and tried
to rob me
you know anything said me Mark
the police pull in the gas station right
there on
on Slauson
and fig you know at the Chevron right
there I know you familiar with the area
and then them guys swooped up instead of
getting any kind of game anything they
wanted they want to come rob me and they
was and they had guns
yesterday was that that's in the old
game they didn't do nothing like that
Mark they didn't wasn't up running up
trying to rob you and kid you now if
just three guys with three guns what you
think they're gonna do with them mark
that's what I'm saying the game has
changed I'm I'm dressed like I am today
got the advertised on the car way more
jewelry on at the time though you see
what I'm saying and that's how it's
changed today and I'll tell you what if
you go out to figure it right now you
got dudes down there Speed Racing up and
down the track jumping out chasing women
down the track all this just stuff to
give the game a black Iron Man call them
whole hustlers
you know what I call him in the way ass
[ __ ] that's what they is they're in
the way and they they got the game all
blurred man all that is not game art
that is from the guys and gangbangers
them drug dealers and Hustlers see what
they do is when international players
come to town they don't know how to talk
to you they want to rob you or they want
to chase your girl around what they're
trying to do is run you out of town you
know what I mean so you it looks all
glamorous you see all these girls out
here and Mark let me tell you something
else the average
hooker in America makes about 400 a day
that's average so you got a lot of below
and you got not and you got some above
you understand what I'm saying the
average stripper in La only bank is two
thousand dollars a month mark these
effects gotta look them up so you got to
say that these got lots of a lot of
these girls out here they're getting 200
225 240. did those are the average now
you got holes and you you've got these
guys they got super hoes super hose is
just natural born holes to check a
thousand fifteen hundred two thousand
three thousand depends on the day but
the average price is my classification
of a super hole is twelve hundred
dollars a day or more a day you're doing
a super good job seeing what the average
is you're doubling over average and a
little bit more
do you think prostitution should be
legalized I actually do think the team
Mark and that's a good question mark
you're a great interview I like you man
in this in this lifestyle it would be
better to legalize prostitution and put
it in a controlled area because you see
plus some places in Mexico in in
Southern America they got one spot I
looked up they got a part where you with
the girls to date in the car they pull
into like a farm area and you know how
you have those car washes like that they
could pull right into the stall date the
guys in a secure environment and they
can drive them right back to the track
if we could have that control situation
over here it would cut back on a lot of
the crime it it cut back on all the
seriousness to go with the game you know
and you know what the longer goes
without the murder the robberies the
rapes and all these type of things that
would go all the way matter of fact uh
you know they made it so uh uh uh for
Lord and for prostitution here in
California there's no crime no more
so they're on the right track the right
steps but I think to get prostitution
legal in America make it taxable is to
create a lot of revenue for the American
government
in in in in in in in a closed setting
and it had revenue for us and we could
take that same revenue from the hookers
and start you know giving it to the
homeless put a homeless something
together you know what I mean just to
improve our environment you know what I
mean so in my opinion yes I think it
should be legal and like in some places
you know it's certainly like in in some
parts of Nevada you know it's got that
legal like the Mustang Ranch and stuff
like that we need to spread that abroad
not only to Roth but street workers too
like I said and have that closed
environment where they could just park
and and date and do the thing and it
would make things a lot better and all
that other crime that goes with it would
go away
but most of it anyway I can't say it go
away 100 percent pimps are one of the
most hated
segments of of society is the most hated
probably yeah pedophiles what do you
what would you say I mean what do people
not understand about temps I mean I know
there's many different types see first
of all you kind of answer the question
there are many different types you got
to remember pivot is a is a job title
it's the man itself
that gets into the game it will give the
game a black guy make it hate it because
all you hear about is they make women go
to Fourth they force them into
prostitution they kidnapping them they
raping them they do hell against their
will but that's so far from true
it's ridiculous that's it I would say in
about I was I wouldn't even give it
seven or eight percent of the of the
overall 100 scope that that actually
happens you know what I mean and that's
why the laws are going up for people
like that but overall pimps are not not
I know I wasn't a bad person I can't
speak for each individual Mark so it's
kind of a blanket statement statement
I'm making here you know what I mean
what kind of qualities does a woman need
in order to do this kind of work what do
you look for well what you got to first
of all first of all Mark and just as
I've studied this a little bit right a
lot of women that get in the game is
these have been uh molested
by the uncles or fathers or brothers
they've been in foster care been
molested abused by the foster care
system so those types of women come out
of that strong because they had to
survive all of that so that so that it
has to be a person that that that's kind
of been through something to be able to
go through something especially being in
this type of game now they got some
people that ain't nothing everybody's
not like that but a high percentage and
I don't want to miss quota percentage
but the high percentage comes from that
background or you know they came from
the mother on welfare uh the mother was
on drugs you know the speed meth heroin
and they grew up like that seeing that
environment and some of them just wanted
better their lives and I'll tell you
what Mark a lot of women that be on
drugs and get a man they'll they'll end
up putting their daughters out you
understand what I'm saying I'm gonna
tell you something else mark
sixty percent of the team that I had I
met their families
and once they got to know me as who I am
and knowing that's the way the dollars
was
they got my blessing because you know
what I always respect to help their
families their sisters their brothers
some of them had kids out there a lot of
the women in the game either their
grandmother got the kids or their mamas
got their kids they get in the little
County check but they wasn't getting an
extra so I would try to give them some
extra money like I said put something to
decide for them they really try to help
them and their families you know
you believe in karma
yes I'm leaving Karma yeah how does
karma play out in your life well I went
to jail
that's how comfortable played out for me
I went to jail but it's a part of the
game that's about I didn't go to jail
for pimping I went to jail for Miss
Pippen that's making sure this make this
true and correct right when you miss me
if you go to jail you pick it right you
don't go to jail but yeah karma is a
mother then I'm gonna say when you
stitch by Karma all those guys that beat
the women
forced the women do all those that thing
that brings that Karma back on you it's
gonna come back to them
double or more you know what I mean so
all so when they get it oh I got 20
years oh I got 30 oh yeah well how was
you acting when you got him
that's Karma do you regret getting into
the game
no I don't I don't reveal it how old are
you now uh you know I'm yesterday man
you did what I'm saying yeah I'm ageless
you've been around yeah okay how about
that yeah if you had your life to live
all over again what would you have done
differently
well you know what Mark I'd say this for
you but I I'm a religious man we're all
in the Book of Life already Mark you
couldn't change your life if you wanted
to
because guess what
and I could have been born a thousand
years ago and you could have been born
two thousand years from now and guess
what we wouldn't be having this
interview if God didn't want us doing it
here now Mark
how about that
so there's there's lots of drama and
Chaos in the life that you lead I mean
tell me tell me some of the stories
about some of the girls you've worked
with or well some of your friends yeah
uh unfortunately you know I I've been I
was blessed to be in the game for a very
long time and I I've only had one girl
that actually got killed in the game and
she was messing with the what the the
what's a mafia won't say which one and
when she got with me she was dating one
of the guys and so she's some kind of
way she owed them some money in them up
yeah yeah yeah with my I won't say which
one right I'm gonna leave that alone but
they wouldn't even take the money back
Mark
they want to take her life instead I've
had uh it was interested in the game
though well here let's I'm this is this
is a very good topic do you remember the
Green River Killer I don't do Green
River Killer started in Seattle he went
all up and down all the West Coast
murdering women on the track
then we had another incident in
Bakersfield was another killer out there
killing all the women on the track so
there's a lot of tragedy that you really
don't hear about the backstory of how
that goes you know what I'm saying the
serial killers the rapists and women
have been some kind of stabbed and you
know that in some case hit with a
hatchet so it's it's a lot of tragedy in
the game that's really unspoken that
really needs to be talked about and
dressed you know what I'm saying mark
it's a very dangerous lifestyle it's a
very very dangerous and I want to say
this here if you've got something that's
better to do find another occupation and
that's real talk I'm just telling you
from Benny Max protector I don't care if
you pimps don't like it and what you got
to say this is my own mouth and I can
say what I got to say is doing all the
tragedy and trying but somebody got
something to do something different try
something different go to school get
your education man try to visit
yourselves as a pimp Your Role is to be
not just their money manager but their
Mentor right what other things among
other things you know what I'm saying of
course of course you you psychologist
you your lover in my case since I kept a
lot of religion in my household you
brought the prisons of religion into the
household and stuff like that you know
here you basically do everything you
know what I'm saying and uh you know and
like I know you've heard this before but
your girls are like your wives you know
what I'm saying it's like it's like
being in Utah you got eight or nine
girls together you know what I'm saying
so every all of them are like your wives
if you treat if you treat the game right
that's it's a it's a lot of game I'm
gonna tell you something else Mark a lot
of pimps get killed I'm gonna tell you
let me give you an instance about how
dangerous it is for us
like the statement I told you over on
Figueroa now we we in Hollywood on
Sunset
this girl gangbang girl came by and was
talking just talking crazy to us right
and said you say something I go get my
men he'll come get all y'all Mark you
understand me I left and guess what
happened
that man ran up saying you guys pimps
and started trying to gun everybody down
so it's very it's very dangerous not
just for them for us too you understand
what I'm saying so it's a lot of that
backstory though that they haven't heard
they've had they've had pimps get killed
by tricks you understand what I'm saying
those type of things are unspoken that
you know really needs to be addressed so
it's actually really dangerous for us
also Mark that you I've watched some
interviews that the other pimps hadn't
talked about so that thank you for
answering that question I mean asking
that question
and Vinnie what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life well you know you know you
know the game it it humbled me because I
actually felt for each individual that I
had you understand what I'm saying so to
me it became a humbling experience being
in the game and I also a grateful
experience because to like I said to
have women trust in me believe in me and
actually virtually put my life into
their hands it like I said it was just
all so humbling man you know what I mean
it's very humbling experience Mark you
know to me it was fascinating exciting
and you know of course we got a lot of
money at the same time you know what I'm
talking about
yeah all right Vinnie Mack thank you so
much for sharing your story okay May
thank you Mark I appreciate you baby we
wish you the best of luck out there all
right yeah all right man thank you